oh just wanted to introduce this duck
it's a spoiler for the book readers I
won't give anything away
think about it
hey youtubers is Charlie so Jaime
Lannister posted a funny video what does
it mean he's holding a duck he says it's
a book spoiler as you probably inferred
from the title of the video the duck
implies there might be a secret
Targaryen in season five of Game of
Thrones
it could be Nikolaj coster-waldau just
just making a joke it could have
absolutely nothing to do with the show
the actors do that all the time most of
them have not read the books but I
wanted to explain the easter egg from
the books what the duck means and my top
four picks for secret Targaryen on the
show that is there's so many more
characters in the books I just I wanted
to keep this more specific to the show
so all of my picks are people that are
on the show I will say mild spoiler
warning for fan theories these are all
just based on fan theories none of this
is canon from the books so here we go
starting with the duck the duck is an
Easter Egg for Raleigh duck filled a
character that's part of young grift
storyline in the books he's a young
character that fled the Seven Kingdoms
after he beat the out of the son of
his liege lord joined the golden company
and ended up serving young Griff young
Griff goes on tonight him but because
he's a lowborn person he doesn't have a
surname he has no coat of arms when
young Griff knights him he's in a field
of ducks
so all of their friends start calling
him duck just to be funny so he takes
the name duck field so he becomes sir
Raleigh duck field and eventually he
becomes part of Young grifs new
Kingsguard because the show has largely
cut out the young Griff storyline this
video is a big mystery you know what
does it mean as is the case with a lot
other characters like Eric storm and
Gendry what's possible is is that they
married the young Griff storyline with
the Dornish master plan and they're
gonna give that to another character
that they already have on the show that
brings us to secret Targaryen theories
and for those asking I think young Griff
is a Blackfyre I don't think he's really
a Targaryen in case you don't know what
a Blackfyre is that's just shorthand for
a certain type of Targaryen bastard
mostly bastards associated or that were
born out of the Blackfyre rebellion
bastards and Westeros are mostly named
based on the region that they're born in
so technically most Targaryen bastards
would be called rivers so when people
say that young Griff is a Blackfyre it
just means that he descends from a
Targaryen bastard born during that
period during that conflict so just an
order from like least likely to most
likely here my top
pigs for people on the show that might
secretly be Targaryen
just to take this video in the most
literal context possible I'll say number
four Jaime Lannister obviously we know
that's not true
there's no way that Jaime is secretly a
Targaryen because he's Circe's twin and
the only notable runnin that we know
about his mother having with a Targaryen
preceded the birth of another Lannister
so by all accounts Cersei and Jaime both
Tywin's children which leads me to
number three you know slightly more
credible fan theories still very
unlikely Tyrion Lannister a lot of fans
think that Tyrion in the books is
secretly a Targaryen because his mother
Joanna Lannister was accosted by Aerys
Targaryen upwards of nine months before
his birth Aerys hated Tywin because he
was secretly afraid of him remember this
is Tywin Lannister most powerful man in
Westeros so he took every opportunity to
do awful things to Tywin creepin all
over his wife Joanna during a big
tournament was just one of those moments
later in life he made Jaime Lannister a
Kingsguard just to spite Tywin
Kingsguard can inherit property so he
thought he was robbing Tywin of his heir
because he knew Tywin would never give
Casterly Rock to Tyrion so in his crazy
fire addled mind he thought he was
destroying Tywin's legacy here's why I
think the show is not gonna back this
theory I think it's just gonna align
Tyrion with Daenerys in a very simple
way the enemy of my enemy is my friend
he hates his sister hates his family
they want him dead so he needs to get
rid of them the only way to do that is
to align himself with someone more
powerful so it's not so much about him
having strong beliefs about who should
sit on the throne it's just about saving
his tail that might change over time but
right now he's just trying to escape the
noose with a little help from Varys
fares is the one with the grand plan
moving on to number two slightly more
likely Tristen Martell so this is where
we get to the show combining Dornish
master plan with young Griff storylines
just a whole bunch of elements being
collapsed into a very simple idea both
of those storylines in the books
involves starting a new rebellion to
place someone on the throne who is
married to a Targaryen but they are
completely separate the Dornish master
plan in the younger of storylines
completely independent the books that
they don't cross over if you've never
heard about it
the Dornish master plan is this theory
in the books that Prince Doran Martell
original
arranged to marry Arianne Martell his
heir to Daenerys his brother Viserys
because Viserys was kind of an asshat he
got himself killed by Khal Drogo so
Prince Duran had to shuffle some things
around and change the plan that's where
you get to quit Martell so he tries to
get Quentin to marry Daenerys so that he
can combine their forces and they can
take the Iron Throne but Daenerys
doesn't give a about Quentin so it
seems like it's kind of a throwaway
storyline and on top of that the show
isn't doing Quentin and it's not doing
young Griff so it could be combining
some aspects from both of those big
storylines and putting them on Tristan
and I should add Marcella Baratheon to
that equation too because you see
there's a lot of scenes here with Marcel
and Tristan both on the show and in the
books
Tyrion betrothed Myrcella to Tristan so
it's just a small possibility but the
show could be giving this who's super
plot to Marcella and Tristan so I guess
you could call those really like three
big story lines because Marcella has her
own storyline in the books too but at
their core they're all very similar they
have very similar end games putting
someone else on the Iron Throne and my
number one secret Targaryen theory Jon
Snow this is by far the most famous fan
theory you guys all off all probably
heard versions of it or you at least
know it by name
Jon Snow is secretly the son of Lyanna
Stark in a Rhaegar Targaryen so the
theory goes that Rhaegar and Lyanna are
secretly in love but Rhaegar has already
been married to Oberyn and Doran Martell
sister Elia for political reasons and
Liana had been betrothed to Robert
Baratheon one of the realities of
marriage in the Seven Kingdoms is that
most Nobles marry for political reasons
not for love so that that's why I like
the history of Westeros is littered with
so many highborn bastards you also have
a lot of really bored really horny
people there's a lot of that too but you
have to believe that they're a bastards
born out of loving relationships not
just lust here's just like a brief
explainer for the R + L equal J theory
if you guys have never heard it before
there's a tournament at Harrenhal
Rhaegar wins and crowns Lyanna Stark
instead of his wife the future Queen of
the Seven Kingdoms everyone in their
sister pretty much knows that that
Rhaegar fancies Liana
but he's already married to someone else
so they can't do anything about it so
everyone else involved in the situation
is super pissed
it's like Rhaegar slapping a bunch of
people in the face but by
accounts Lyanna stark also fancied him
and just for context at this time she's
about Sansa Starks age jorge art martin
writes that a while later just just like
a vague amount of time later he absconds
with her and they hole up in the tower
of joy this isn't the cause of Robert's
rebellion but it is the first in a chain
of events that led to the rebellion
eventually Ned Stark learns that Leon is
being kept at the Tower of joy and goes
to rescue er when he arrives Rhaegar
Targaryen isn't there he left
Lyanna stark in the care of his
Kingsguard he had to leave because
Robert's rebellion had started this is
where it gets a little fuzzy because
there's no official timeline as to the
date she and Rhaegar disappeared in the
date Ned found her but it is long enough
for a baby to gestate
speaking of which Ned Stark finds Liana
in a room that smells of blood and roses
is this as how it's described in the
book she's dying of a really bad fever
and infection as she slowly passes she
extracts a promise from Ned Stark we
don't know what the promise was only
that she said promise me Ned and he
agreed Rhaegar was killed by Robert
Baratheon at the Battle of the Trident
supposedly when he was dying he
whispered the name of a woman the only
evidence we have that is in one of
Daenerys as visions so way way back when
Daenerys was in the house of the undying
and she had all those different visions
they didn't do another show they cut out
of the show but in the books she has a
vision of Rhaegar dying at the Trident
whispering a woman's name we don't know
what the name is only that it's a
woman's name so do the math he probably
whispered Liana
the promise Ned Stark made was probably
to protect the baby quote-unquote Jon
Snow like I said though that is all just
like a really big fan theory nothing has
been confirmed by Martin we have no idea
when he's going to confirm it the funny
thing is is the David Benioff has a
shirt that says R plus L equals J on it
right here so it's just him just having
a little bit of fun with us here's my
big question for you guys just looking
at the people that are on the show do
you think that anyone is secretly a
Targaryen and doesn't know it I know
there have been a lot of comments about
what Dan and Dave said about the show
spoiling stuff from the books I mean I
put it the clip of my last Game of
Thrones video just because it was such a
big deal if I didn't mention it then
I'll just say that I don't think that
anything in season 5 is going to spoil
the books in a big way there might be a
few characters that will get into their
wins
winter storylines most notably Sansa
Stark I think if anyone is at risk in
season 5 of doing winds of winter stuff
its Sansa so don't freak out too bad and
if you don't read the books obviously
you don't care because I posted this
today I'm probably gonna wait to post my
next game of Thrones bonus video until
sometime during next week there's like a
whole lot of Walking Dead stuff this
weekend I want to get through so be sure
to subscribe to get everything feel free
to leave me a request for bonus videos
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner David Robles you and a $20 Amazon
gift card be sure to direct message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact info and for those that
are asking it should be like the
beginning of April when the HBO now
service rolls out once that happens
that's what the giveaway is going to be
for until we get to Episode one and then
episode one is what I'm gonna do the
giveaway for the sign George our Martin
books for those that are asking
giveaways are open to international
people all you have to do to enter is
just be a subscriber really simple and
leave a comment on whichever video the
new round start in while you guys wait
for my next bonus video you can click
here for my top 5 Daenerys Targaryen
predictions for season 5 and you can
click here to learn about what HBO has
planned for the future of the show after
season 6 thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you